bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale télé
avec jean baptiste oiseaux stephen alors
jean baptiste aujourd'hui on va voir une
variante connu pour être un gambit
extrêmement agressif qui n'a jamais été
réfutée d'ailleurs et qui est tout à
fait intéressant à jouer avec et noir
voilà jamais entièrement réfuté on a
toujours cru avoir une piste peut-être
pour poser des problèmes et puis
finalement ça perçoit comme d'autres
variantes comme ça un peu tendu qu'il ya
toujours une solution pour avoir du jeu
c'est le gambit benko candide un
coquillier on va dire au début du pion
nam pour les noirs ce qu'est le camp dit
marshall dont les pions iso pour le pion
vert c'est-à-dire un gambeat totalement
inefficace qu'on va totalement voilà
donc est à dire
en gambie bon par définition qui en
échange du pire on propose des
compensations dynamique durable durable
comme tu le disais c'est comme le gambit
marshall voilà les deux marshalls sur
l'espagnol est à granby comparables
évidemment pas dans la position bien sûr
l'esprit en tout cas dans un avion pour
initiatives durables et puis surtout
avec des très bons résultats mais mon
meilleur niveau quoi surtout ça alors on
va voir ça tout de suite
ce gang dit banco alors après des quatre
classiques début du pion dame cavaliers
6 c4 tout de suite maintenant le coup un
des couples et enfin qui mène aux
gambier que même coup le voilà les
émirats vont mener quelques coups de
manière violente contre le centre blanc
en questionnant tout de suite les pions
blancs qui qui sont autant qu'ils sont
au centre
c'est cette voie là tout de suite donc
devoir alors ça c'est un pseudo
sacrifice puisque si les blancs prennent
on peut toujours éventuellement faire
damas cinq échecs un suivi d'un procès
s'est joué entre autres elle peut aussi
jouer peut-être néo cons comme 6 des
cocons cavalia six exactement cavalia et
6 g6 coup j'essaie de sa langue de la
situation fait c'est pas un vrai hein
c'est pas très intéressant pour les
blancs dont les blancs vont plutôt
essayer de garder le contrôle sur le
centre en dessin en jouant des 5
voilà donc là on a plusieurs
possibilités mais ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est le bambi benko
baie-saint-paul ap st alors donc là un
coup extrêmement agressif puissant
puisque on donne un pion à le plomber
s'inquiétant prise quand même tout de
suite on voit aussi qu'en plus une fois
pris il sera protégé
potentiellement par le fouet fin c'est
un vrai grand midi en tout cas ce
brigand by très clair que les noirs
n'ont pas l'intention de le récupérer
rapidement
d'ailleurs il ne pourrait pas le faire
on si vous en avez envie
et alors là la meilleure réputation d'un
envie évidemment c'est de l'accepter
c'est ce qu'on dit souvent en
l'occurrence c'est vrai que les
meilleures lignes passent par la
fluctuation avec ses proches des cinq
donc c'est prendre les 5
voilà donc là eh bien on va voir l'idée
du gambit donc c'est de jouer à 6 ans et
le coût principal évidemment à 6 l'idée
c'est de dire voilà si les blancs prénom
à si je reprends du fou j'ai gagné un
temps de développement pour ça et puis
la grande idée c'est que j'ai deux
colonnes ouverte ici voilà qui vont
taper à la fois sur le plan b deux sur
le pion à deux avec un très bon jeu al
alam on va voir que l'idée des noirs est
très cohérente on a vraiment des pièces
qui sont coordonnés sur la même partie
de l'échiquier tu parlais du collège a
et b tu avais raison
voilà une belle idée en tout cas b5 puis
on prend à 6 voilà notre ami ben co qui
a popularisé peut-être pas découvert
mais populariser ce derby
en tout cas nous a donné de bien belle
idée de bien belles choses à discuter
aujourd'hui
alors là ici et des embranchements pour
lui blanc alors quoi si billy a trois
possibilités essentiel voilà
essentiellement trois possibilités alors
il ya de l'acceptation b prend à six
dont on va parler majoritairement quand
même dans cette émission puisque c'est
bien sûr une position typiques du granby
benko il ya aussi la déclinaison avec b
6 mais si son profil intéressant car il
ya beacoup fondamental parce qu'en fait
on concède le vent me met en vente des 6
pour lui évidemment les noirs pourront
prendre avec la dame ou éventuellement
attendre de jouer cavalier 17 car
l'épreuve et 6 bon il est surtout l'idée
c'est que le fossé 8 tout de suite aimé
il se développera pas habitués à bien
résumé c'est c'est pas un problème
pour les blancs de se séparer du pion du
moment que les pièces noires restent
embouteillée en fait n'oublions pas que
les blancs quand même une avance au
centre donc c'est pas vraiment ce qui se
passe sur la dame qui est intéressant
ils vont en fait donné ce pion et puis
il y les noirs vont mettre du temps
avant de le récupérer dans de bonnes
conditions en tout cas activer leurs
pièces dans de bonnes conditions et en
ce temps les blancs vont accentuer leur
chef de centre
troisième grande idée f3 rockwell 3 qui
voit là bon ok qui qui est bon on ne
manque pas d'intérêt il ya des choses de
façon de rendre le plus grand en fait on
veut jouer aux quatre ici c'est clair et
on veut pas jouer le coup cavale et c3
puisque après à prendre mais 5 pour
prendre du cavalier ouais bah il n'est
pas très bien en place et encore ce qu'a
choisi je vais dans ma 5ème gain de
temps et si on reprend pas à gabés 4
derrière qui valent elles gênent et donc
on joue f3 plutôt qu'à les c3 pour
protéger le pion à 4 évidemment voilà f3
donc apprend b5
alors après un bep 5 on peut aggraver
d'abord cette ligne e 4 alors c'est
intéressant le cadre parce que en menace
de récupérer le plan b 5 avec le fou et
en même temps de faire avancer le
rouleau compresseur au centre avec de
4,5
aussi si un civil qui renverrait le
cavalier sa case initiale ce qui serait
pas forcément une très bonne nouvelle
pour les noirs mais on verra ses chères
études
voilà exactement sodam à cinq échecs et
d'amasser pas mal depuis que ça protège
le pion le tueur b5 protège le pion des
cinq attaques le croit blanc voilà donc
là il ya une position intéressante qui
surviendra pas fou des deux fous d2b 4
donc là la dame est attaqué la menace de
4,5 aussi est toujours dans l'air voilà
potentiellement et c'est le coup de b4
que je voulais jouer voilà le foie en d2
quand même l'inconvénient d'avoir coupé
la dame d induction des 5
la dame diane protège plus présente pas
vraiment simple mais là maintenant on a
un coup à notre disposition qui à coup
très intéressant qui est cavalier à 3,4
voilà en profitant du clouage du pur b4
le fou clou le plan b car adam se trouve
derrière et le cavaly va trouver une
case vraiment très intéressante pour
venir soutenir ses plans sans trop dans
leur avance et en plus ce soir mans
gagné un temps soi d'un simple bien sûr
on peut montrer par exemple quelques
coups dé 6,6 cavaliers c4 il faut bouger
adamence et 7 donc la dame ans et sept
sur un bon encore une très jolie course
est partie du néerlandais ivan sokolov
ca3 parce qu'on va forcer le plan b 4 à
prendre une décision pourquoi parce que
encore sadaka c3 sera libéré une autre
fois pour aller en c3 toujours pour
soutenir la poussée de 4 5 mètres se
fout en c3 pour à la fois libéré le
contrôle de la case des cinq sur la dame
est contrôlé une superbe diagonale ici
avec attaque sur le cassis aussi donc
cette variante intéressante stéphane
n'est pas très joué mais nous montre
quand même une première idée dans cette
ouverture c'est que les blancs joue
toujours pour la pousser eux 5 voilà ils
veulent ouvrir au centre mais sur voilà
pour la pousser à eux cinq ils dominent
au centre ils veulent accentuer cette
domination
donc là on a vu un abus la brillante
avec f3 au progrès des entailles b6
éventuellement maintenant alors après à
six dont combien de voix séparant avec
f3 maintenant la possible à deux
possibilités c'est le coût b6 aussi très
important voilà alors je me suis trompé
puisque j'ai joué à quake 3 c'est idiot
donc le bcc voile alors qu'on revient
sur le devant avec b6 et on va suivre la
partie du prodige américain nakamura
dans une partie très récente à la
constituante circuite donc on va
regarder comme ryad où cette partie avec
l'humour et de cette année de cette
année fin de cette année 2008 en fait de
2007 qu'il a gagné 2 ce n'est gagné or
c'est un circuit à gagner et on va voir
que son style
correspond bien à cette ouverture ou en
tout cas que cette ouverture correspond
bien à son style plutôt puisqu'il a un
style où il cherche à activer ses pièces
le plus vite possible donc des six on
voit qu'il n'est pas pressé de récupérer
le pion le plomb et annotations
cavaliers ses trois essais on développe
les pièces cavaliers 17
voilà il va plutôt essayer de prendre
part à nantes du cavalier en fait voilà
cavaliers f3 carlin l'estran en entre le
développement classique
nous on a l'air de passer un peu vite en
tout cas c'est toujours comme ça c'est
vrai qu'on développe cette pièce avec
les noirs c'est ça qui fascinait
cladribine cause c'est qu'on place telle
pièce à peu près toujours la même façon
sur faut comprendre quelques petites
idées additionnel mais c'est comme ça
alors bonjour j si sûr que ça on ne veut
pas jouer aussi parce que c'est les
blancs qu'ils veulent exploser le ca en
train qui veulent jouer au service des
blancs sont mieux placés au sort des
prix aussi s'affaiblir et le pion des
six donc non il faut il faut jouer le g6
avec un très bon choix là on le
contourne le centre avec cette
disposition dragon voilà disposition en
quoi la dragon ghetto le fond feuillatre
au quat'sous g7 bouger cette fois eu
deux les deux corps rockets petit rôle
tout à fait classique pâtira tombé huit
tours de 8
la cavalier d2 on comprend bien l'idée
c'est pour revenir ans éclate alors
qu'on veut à la menace enfin la menace à
pseudomonas et devenez ans est également
tombé six évidemment et toujours en
prise oui mais c'est possible pour
soutenir la vence 5 est aussi libéré le
pion bref éventuellement pour toujours
apparaître pousser et 405 pour la
bataille est pacsé mis des cavaliers pro
b 6 là j'aime bien les coups qui suivent
à quatre alors à cannes l'idée est
simple la iv évidemment veut jouer à 5
suivi de cavale et ses 82 qu'un très
beau cas rien ses cadres la casse v6 qui
sera totalement sous contrôle
donc c'est un c c'est un très joli coup
sur le cou noir à 5
on peut peut-être en parler se serait
positionné lmnp pas très brillant
puisque on aurait une case b5 faible et
voilà le cavalier comme tu me montres
pourraient surgir sur la classe b 5 et
la tourbe et 8 serait complètement
inefficace sur ses colonnes ouverte sur
1,5 potentiellement faible aussi avec
des concombres ou des deux des coups
comme damien éventuellement même cavalli
b3 avec une pression énorme sur ce sens
notamment pour ses options tout en est
un
une case des scènes totalement sous
contrôle avec le pion à 4 et le fouet
deux qui contrôle cette case
on voit bien qu ici donc là ce serait
une grosse erreur puisque on a donné une
case essentiels aux blancs surtout pas
tomber dans cette erreur mais jouer le
cavalier f17 libérant le fougueux 7
on libère le fou g7 et on va voir l'idée
des noirs de ceux de replacements
importante aussi puisque après 3h un
rouage suite de coups prophylactique
oui c'est à 5 et la kabylie à 8,8
ces très bons cavaliers c'est quand même
très bon même si le capitalisme parce
qu'en fait il va revenir très vite sur
le christ et 7 en contrôlant
parfaitement à 6 et surtout et voyant
produire 4,5 puis la case des quatre
voisins et bien sûr au final des quatre
qui est protégé par le fou voilà je
voyais que c'est un peu c'est un peu
originales comme trajet mais en tout cas
c'est l'idée ça fait partie de ces
ouvertures comme l'estonienne où les
noirs doivent un peu de cases de faire
des miracles à valeur canali exactement
ouais c'est souvent un peu ça donc là
qu'avaient laissé 4 pour les blancs qui
continuent leurs plans oui cavalli ces
sept on recycle c'est vrai on peut aussi
dire que les blancs vont avoir un bon
cavalier en b 6 années maintenant c'est
la case mais si c'est lyon qui est
faible après le très joli coup double en
suivant cavalia 4 art dé ces deux
cavaliers superbe sont prêts à bondir
on a profité de calais c7 et que le pion
à 5 des plus en prise de la dame
marqueurs avoir non plus le ciel que les
c4 en fait là en tout cas les deux
cavaliers sont prêts à bondir sur mes
six pouces et surtout que le cavaly
n'est plus en 1 8es contre le clou à la
balle tôt j'ai comme l'impression que la
case des quatre est plus intéressante
pour les voir que donnait la case b6
alors on va voir ça tout de suite allé
après calais b 5 mai sur cale y avait
six bons c'est une case mais ils
n'attaquent pas grand chose sur kameni
finalement tout de suite hein et là qui
avait des cas très bons cavaliers la
très jolie cavaliers prêt à échanger et
éventuellement ici il est centralisé
protégé pour toucher cette somme c'est
pas mal des trois fours 17 des trois
tubes et c'est là du noir est très clair
peut-être pas aller plus loin c'est de
jouer des coups qui brise le centre
comme f5 ou e6 maintenant f5 va bien on
est prêt parce que toutes nos pièces
noires contrôle le centre alors
parfaitement à la fois en 1 impression
sur les cases blanches avec les deux
fous
une pièce centrale et quand on a deux
fois en 5 et tout comme cela il faut
viser de tiffauges et c'est là qu'une
seule envie c'est que le centre
disparaisse pour que les fous s'exprime
pleinement bien sûr les fous soit à fond
et tape le plus loin possible dans le
camps et tout à fait donc voilà comment
on peut jouer quand on joue b6 avec les
blancs alors on va s'intéresser
maintenant peut-être aux grandes lignes
de ce robin co donc là il va falloir
aussi juste avant qu'on revient à
grandes lignes sur cette position-là
fort que les blancs eux essayé de
bétonner le centre de regarder la
position tendu faire alors ils ont des
autres quand même effectivement
peut-être passer un petit peu vite mais
quand même le les purs blanc de tianwan
ne bouge pas facilement comme ça mais
cela si vous bougez un f5 et en russie
ça fait des affaiblissements les pièces
blanches quand même assez bien placé sur
donc voilà c'est une partie vraiment où
les deux camps des pièces active
voici une partie tendue il faut aimer le
combat donc c'est vraiment une ouverture
de combat cette ouverture là donc alors
à 6 donc en fait bizarrement c'est plus
l'acceptation du bambi qui permet de
jouer un truc positionner le plus beau
et plus tranquille et bray oui alors on
va faire puis on prend 1,6 à celle avant
de reprendre s'ils acceptent comme butin
alors là on a deux ordres de coups
possibles qui revient strictement au
même soit on fait tout prend 1,6 soit on
joue des 6 ou g6 peu importe j'ai six
c'est quand même un peu plus logique
c'est un peu pareil ça peut paraître
douteux sont des pièces vont sur les
mêmes 15 ans alors on y va on va on va
choisir tout simplement fou prend 1,6 y
est plus logique alors on va regarder
fou prend à six parce que la petite
différence c'est que le fou en fait
empêche le pion empêche entre guillemets
le pion eu de bouger puisque hand et
recrée le roi blanc chose qui vous allez
le voir
n'effraie pas vraiment les blancs dans
beaucoup de vent ni benko puisqu'on
trouve un abri quand même avec g3 et 3g
2 voilà messieurs fou prend à 6 on va
regarder quand même comment les blancs
peuvent jouer quand ils n'ont pas envie
de se faire des rockets là il ya une
petite variante pas très connu black
elle est jouée par de très très fort
joueur mais qui est très intéressante
c'est la variante que l'on va voir
stéphane avec cavaliers trois cavaliers
des deux on va comprendre le retour
alors on y va vous prend à seaska et c3
et c3 la d6 des six et là on n'a pas
envie de jouer le 4 bien que c'est le
coup qu'on ait envie sur quatre c'est
possible c'est possible mais pour ceux
qui n'ont pas envie d'avoir le roi des
rockets qui sont pas à l'aise quand le
roi du chemin à faire et bien dans cette
manoeuvre intéressante qui va devoir 3g
6 et 6 et là cavalier d2 avec une double
idée les cascades mais surtout protéger
le fou efforts pour tâche de fond f1
messieurs voilà et surcouche de 7,7
maintenant maintenant on joue et blanc
jouent eux 4 4 et surtout prend efforts
en plus que surprenant cavaliers pros f1
mais ça change pas grand chose en fait
ça change pas grand chose rare au rock
en un seul coup de jouer le court
apprend enfin j'ai trois rangées 2 voilà
ça fait des affaiblissements - quand
même c'est intéressant mais ça mais bon
ça produites entre le cavalière et trois
qualités de steve wallace et ça c'est
une petite subtilité mais au final on se
retrouve à peu près dans les mêmes
positions elle avait des joueurs qui
nous écoutent peut-être qu'il n'aime pas
d'évoquer tout simplement que c'est bien
sûr qu'il préfère avoir alors à noter qu
en scène la dame vieira 5 c'est sa
position naturelle souvent donc la torah
8 damascène déjà commencé à voir une
batterie 6 sur la colonne ac est quand
même bien alors et on va mettre après
l'avoir ok on va voir comment la
deuxième tour va venir avaient vite
voilà très souvent il faut faire une
batterie en priorité sur la colonne à
que ce soit avec damas simple ou d'abord
bouger la tour émettre la dame derrière
en a 8 mai sur vingt huit ans à 8 où
elles contrôlent à la fois la donne a et
aussi à la nouille sur le centre voilà
tout à fait c'est un double it est alors
foutez de veut balayer deux petit rock
petit rat lieu trois ans maintenant que
le cavalier fait son oeuvre il faut se
bouger
quatre ans on va faire petit rock bien
sûr cavale et b17 petit rush chez roc
dames à 6 comme ces deux là on peut
éventuellement s'arrêter c2c une
position classique 1 oui peut-être joué
le coup d'après peut-être tour v8 c'est
ça a été joué s'il tombe et 8 et le coup
joué par fait que la rof pas tout de
suite dans la poursuite
voilà en tout cas ça serait quand même
l'idée le dr m de mettre la pression sur
une possibilité tout simplement c'est de
jouer tout voilà avec la position
classique de l'abm qu on a dit rien
alors c'est ça c'est ça la position
classique en appréciant ici double
pression sur les colombes et sur la lame
a essayé de rapprocher petit à petit les
cavaliers blanc verdel dame qu'on soit
là pour essayer de préparer une petite
combinaison et c'est comme ça que ça
joue mais blanc en contrepartie peuvent
jouer avec le coup f4 qui peut être très
intéressant dans beaucoup de cas et qui
là encore ne paraît assez beau puisque
on prépare la poussée e5 tranquillement
bien sûr voilà donc ça cette variante
plus tôt avec cavaliers des deux camps
les chronos et blanc n'ont pas envie
d'être des roquettes est sûre alors à la
place de donc on va revenir à [ __ ] en
a si souvent fou prend 1,6 alors là vous
prend 1,6 pour les noirs on vous le dit
lord ne change rien c'est une autre
variante met donc à saâles passe de ce
coup là c'est ça le b36 donc la géci
soit là tout ça finalement là ici j'ai 6
voilà cavaliers c3 c3 est un peu
différent on va voir ce qu'on va
retrouver un taux de l'appareil
là on n'hésite pas à jouer le 4 4 on
peut ouais faut prendre fou prend à
prendre on apprendra par an der ok mais
c'est pas grave puisque le voilà
plancher on va voir dans la manoeuvre
qui nous permet de replacer le roi des 6
et 6 g iii chez 3 voilà on trouve
d'autres petit abri ancien ghetto très
loin de ce rock à la main c'est un roc à
la main voilà très loin de toutes les
nuisances de l'ale dame
cavalieri 17 meddle le port est très
classique cavaliers y croire donc c'est
un peu pareil on va en trouver la même
idée évidemment petit rock
ben oui tu as raison c'est pas très
différent h3 alors il faut préciser le
courage 3 quand même parce que ce serait
c'est un coup que l'on connaît mais
pourquoi le coup h3 et parce que le fou
j'ai c'est qu'il a envie de jouer
voilà donc le g7 a envie de jouer pour
que le fou g7 joue il faut que le
cavalier en f 6 disparaissent et très
souvent on propose deux cavaliers vite
devenir angers 4 puis en u15 parce qu'il
a des cases blanches intéressante après
ici ces quatre on peut pas jouer b3 tout
de suite parce que vous la laissiez
trois rangs des gones allemand avec la
tour 1 est sous la menace du fou donc
cdma 9 aussi donc on joue c'est souvent
le coup qu'il faut pas oublier voilà à
je crois à la tour tout raciste c'est
bien de voir ce couple bien sûr
puisqu'on on en avait parlé
c'est une autre façon de réaliser la
batterie sur la colonne heures batterie
plus je dirais plus naturel aussi un oui
c'est pas plus mal de m adam derrière la
tour qui vaut moins pour préparer une
combinaison épiant à 8 et a quand même
un bon oeil sur le centre ce qui va
quand retarder d'autant rendre délicat
la poussée ou 5 puisque cela va
affaiblir le pion des cinq évidemment la
tourbe et un pour les blancs alors tombé
1 puisque on a envie de faire un blocus
et les blancs sur l'ale dame en jouant
b3 four b2 oui donc aller on veut
enlever aussi la tour delà de la menace
du fou g7 tout à fait où l'on divise à
vivre et b3 cas ici mais en b3 est
possible si l'on avait juste avant il y
avait qu ali prend 1,4 point noir laqué
lèvres 17 6 heures pour les noirs oui de
rapatrier leurs cavaliers n'a pas pu
passer par g4 donc on a trouvé cavaliers
b6 cavaliers fdcl on va pouvoir
peut-être aller 1-5 et il le faisait
cette menace tout de suite moi ça y est
le câble et ses trois foulées d'olt et
logique damas huit et la dame et 8 a
regardé comme si jolie maintenant très
belle batterie toute l'idée de davydenko
vient faire le pilote de saint est
possible attaque à deux et en plus la
dame très bien patient avec pascal annen
superbe ici sur le plan des cinq as en
liaison avec le climat d'investissement
pression sur le plan des 5 c en cas de
4,5 tout de suite par exemple
bon déjà c'est pas possible puisque
c'est une souris emprise mais le plus
récent est très affaibli de manière
générale avec le roi g2 en plus en ligne
d'eau minérale obtient des sexes sera
affaibli derrière effectivement plus tu
as raison de le signaler il ya le ranger
de au bout donc en toute honnêteté je
dirais qu'il ya pas besoin de connaître
plus pour commencer le temps du bnq
aussi vous avez compris que cette
formation de pièces va poser des
problèmes à l'adversaire c'est que vous
n'avez pas besoin de plus c'est clair
après l'expérience où il causera
peut-être quelques petits soucis dans la
pratique du bain co mais je dirais que
ça c'est pour tous les jours de cette
part est il faut essayer de modifier peu
à peu notre répertoire
mais pour commencer à québec bnq hausse
assez bien voilà si je vous ai compris
que cette disposition est bonne alors
vous avez compris le principal
d'ouverture alors c4 va être possible
aussi voilà on va pouvoir éventuellement
de jouer des camaïeux cinq plus tard
aussi toujours en liaison avec le pouce
et 4 et blanc doivent sans que si le
coin puisque f5 peut être possible aussi
il ya beaucoup de possibilités pour les
noirs tous les blancs mais ils sont
quand même un bon pour deux points de
plus tout de suite les noirs peuvent le
récupérer par dans cette partie ils
jouent tous revin les blancs les noirs
peuvent choisir aussi de récupérer le
pion tout de suite mais bien de prix
quand même partie de michael adams assez
ancienne mais qui très intéressante fou
prend 6 3 on donne le fola revient on
n'a pas trop envie de donner le foot
quasiment avoir des bonnes raisons ce
soit pour les joueurs l'estonienne où
les joueurs de big ben spies 5e tour ne
fait de ne pas le donner parce que les
cases sont faibles après tout reprend à
deux et à tout prendre on a récupéré le
pion mais au prix quand même la faire
attention aux prix quand même d'une
rose affaiblissement des cases mois
voilà donc il va falloir quand même
faire attention à ça mais c'est tout à
fait jouable
donc voila voila les idées se construit
pas la peine de creuser plus sur les
parties mais on a donné ses grandes
idées il ya système finalement
comprendre ce nom beats et dorment ils
plus simple on nous les colonne arrivées
pour les noix ou prix d'un pion certes
mais on voit que très vite les blancs
n'ont pas de possibilité vraiment de
jouer pour un avantage clair parce que
l'on retienne fermement le centre et l
dames et qu'il faut que les blancs
soient patients
pour valoriser leur non plus à à long
terme repassez vous bien les missions
mais l'idée c'est ça en gros mettre le
paquet sur les colonnes a et b et puis
rapprocher nos pièces mineurs de 7 2 7l
dame qui nous intéresse d'ailleurs une
anecdote assez amusante sur le comic
book ou avec un ami débutants qui me
demandait ce qu'il fallait jouer sur des
cas quelque chose de très simple
oui et je te le dis le cabinet bain co
c'est très facile tu fais comme ça tu
mets les pieds sur la gambie a et b des
pièces lourdes et ça va se passer tout
seul et ce qui est très amusant c'est
qu'on peut regarder c'est que
malheureusement son adversaire lui a
joué le coup b6 oui et il a suivi mon
conseil à la lettre mais en poussant le
pion à et en mettant les caisses lourds
derrière le pion à alors c'est vrai que
c'est une ouverture intéressante mais il
faut quand même avoir quelques notions
de dans les échecs et sûrement école
ouverte on met pas les pièces derrière
ses pions voilà faut pas reproduire
bêtement quand même toutes les phrases
qu'on dit c'est sorti ce même s'ils ont
passé mais en l'occurrence ce n'est pas
le cas voilà donc il faut quand même
faire attention un petit peu à ce qu'on
fait et repassez vous l'émission pour
être sûr d'avoir bien bien compris tous
les conseils que vous adonner sur sur 7
bingo voilà comme un coup très facile à
jouer très simple toujours les même coup
les mêmes les mêmes idées après
évidemment faux créé au milieu de jeu et
les bons coups ne pas se tromper dans
l'ordre des coûts faire attention aux
manoeuvres qu'amélie et 4,45 qui peuvent
parfois s'avérer
extrêmement violente un bien sûr on l'a
montré le coatch 3 et souvent possible
pas avoir peur de se faire des rockets
voilà c'est pas c'est pas très grave
avec les blancs donc et on a montré une
technique pour éviter de qu'on soit
défroqué mais en fait on peut très bien
joué j'ai la warner sony veulent pas se
faire des reculs à toute possibilité
cavalière trois cavaliers 2 voilà ben
écoutez ans
merci pour avoir suivi cette façon merci
jean baptiste merci stéphane semaine
prochaine fois au revoir au rebond